here to help us figure this out Mark Jon
American Enterprise Institute senior
fellow Leo Terell civil rights attorney
both are Fox News contributors Mark Penn
joining us as well former Clinton
adviser and pollster and now CEO of
stagwell gentlemen thank you very much
um let me go down the line here Mark and
I'll start with you um how does this
make sense to say well they just I don't
have a choice they forced me um it was
in the book 6 months ago so I have to
use American taxpayer dollarss to just
do what it said that they were going to
do um and and fix this wall for 20 miles
I don't really want to do
it yeah and he says that he doesn't want
to do it it's not needed and his his
Secretary of Homeland Security says
there is an acute acute need uh for it I
mean they've just the the hypocrisy here
is so rank they they you know they they
they called Trump an authoritarian for
using executive authority to build a
wall well guess what they're using the
same executive Authority right now to
wave 26 laws in order to build the wall
uh there's so many things that are going
on here what this shows Martha is this
is a crisis of choice Joe Biden has all
the same laws and all the same
authorities on the books that Donald
Trump and Barack Obama had before him
and he is just choosing not to use them
and it's now gotten to the point where
the crisis is so bad where for three
years in a row we have each year broken
the record for how many encounters we
have we have 1.5 million Goda ways we
have 106,000 people a year dying of
fentanyl that's crossing over the Border
that's like a plane crash every single
day in this country almost 300 people on
the terrorism watch list who have been
arrested at the border and how many more
of those among the 1.5 uh million Goda
ways that have come into that and it's
so bad that even Democrats even the
governor of New York the mayor of New
York are pushing them on it and so
finally they're building the wall so why
don't they just admit that Donald Trump
was right from the beginning yeah I mean
that that's the question Leo you have uh
the mayor of Chicago the mayor of New
York both going one is already there
one's going going south of the border to
plead with people say look we don't have
room for you it's really not wise to
come I it's now falling on these Mayors
to do what the president hasn't done but
what I really can't figure out
politically is when he looks at this
number
62% say that they disapprove of the way
that the president's handling the
immigration situation is is it
completely gone for a politician to say
look I see I see the numbers you know I
feel your pain Bill Clinton style um and
I'm going to fix this but that's not
what we're
hearing no you're not you're never going
to you're not going to hear the only
reason why this is happening Martha is
because of democratic pressure from
Mayors from New York Los Angeles
Governor Abbot did the correcting and
sending the migrants to these other
Democratic Sanctuary cities because it
made it a national issue everyone knows
about it now I want to be very clear I'm
glad I'm on this segment you have je
Karine Jean Pier the press secretary
telling everybody we got to follow the
rule of law they're breaking 26 laws to
follow the rule of law there's only four
people who believe that the border is
secure Kareem Joe Biden Camala Harris
and mayorcas everyone else in this
country knows that the border is broken
and what Joe Biden needs to acknowledge
that Donald Trump was right and he was
wrong and he owed Trump an apology so
Mark politically if you were advising
this President and you see the numbers
and you see the Need For Change how
would you tell him to get you know over
that
hump well look I've been predicting for
the last two months that we would see
the administration
move here because this has become one of
the top three issues 58% say we have
open borders only 36% in in our polls
the Harris poll approve of his position
so look I think they had to move to
close the border I'm I'm a little
surprised that this came out that
they're going to build a physical
barrier given what they've said but they
had no choice this issue was mounting it
was hitting Democratic cities there's
this is the beginning of an election
campaign it's one of the top three
issues this had to happen and it is a
good sign for the reelection campaign
that they're actually doing something
about the my question is this and I
appreciate everything you just said but
the question is is this the most the
most effective way for the president to
say I see I hear I understand I'm
Switching gears he's not saying that
he's saying they got me over a barrel
and I have to do it because Congress
already signed off on it 6 months
ago well look I think Communications on
this could be more effective for sure
yeah no his answers could be more
effective go ahead Mark
pen yeah look I think the the
communications on this could be more
effective I think he could come out and
say that we didn't expect the numbers to
be Crossing that are crossing and the
problems to have created in the cities
and so we're taking action look I I
think he is in an election campaign I
think he's got to take command of the
issues and particularly when you do a
pivot you do have to own that you're
doing a pivot not let the press
secretary give you know somewhat
half-hearted answers thank you very much
gentlemen uh this is a very important
moment in this debate and it's going to
be pervasive throughout the course of
this election how the president is
pivoting here and how he's handling it
thank you all for being here I'm Steve
duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis